thank you
[Music]
we've recently talked about this but I
wanted to talk about it because Joe's
not here so we can actually talk about
it all right we're talking about Japan
today
oh man we need Joe for you people are
shocked to find out how Japan carries
out the death penalty now I thought we
had talked about this recently different
types of death penalties but I realized
that we were talking about it from a U.S
perspective in the different states
and we didn't think about uh different
types of death penalties because I know
that we have really dark minds but
anybody here familiar with Hal or one of
the types of ways that Japan carries out
their death kind ever thought about that
me neither they don't do the old school
like you do it yourself except that's
with honor right that's with honor
that's with honor you have to be that's
an honorable death where they grant you
that that's just gangsters but right
that's kind of sick right it's like it's
like when you lose in a battle myself
yeah and then and then you like you know
you go to the other like the other
[ __ ] Commander or whatever but
they're still willing to pay respect by
giving you a honorable death and
honorable means you stab yourself and
they behead you that's a whole gangster
or you get beheaded by your second in
command so that the honorable people
don't have to I mean sorry your enemy
doesn't get the opportunity oh next yeah
your next in command is kind of like you
know giving you your honor by keeping
that's that's just crazy but I think
that causes PTSD for the second guy in
command if it didn't that'd be [ __ ]
you don't think he's like conflicted at
some point because I think they like it
I know but like it's like a high five
where's Joe we need to ask jokes last
high five of his life is quite the high
five if I had a boss or something and I
really looked up that dude and I had to
chop his head off that'd be rough
that'd be devastating
so as of 2022 55 countries still use the
death penalty as a form of punishment
in 2021 the country broke an almost
two-year execution Hiatus when three men
were killed by the state with Japan's
first execution of 2022 taking place in
July when tomoh Hiro Kato who was
convicted of stabbing seven people to
death in 2008 was hanged
wow I'm gonna guess that wow that's
gangster but the capital punishment uh
is a specific type of hanging it's what
they call a long drop hanging you die
faster
yeah that sounds like the neps it sounds
like it yeah this is where you stand I
look like square games oh it's a
trapdoor oh [ __ ] they do that at like
[ __ ] Bad Bunny concerts yeah they do
just the other way the other way though
not saying any of us understand
but would you rather a a long drop hang
or one of the ones you see in those
westerns where you kind of Choke out
long drop 100 so snap your neck right
away probably die faster right
yeah
for real you want to struggle you don't
want a [ __ ] chiropractor just doing
the one final pull I think if I if I had
someone just choke me out to sleep
that's probably the best way to go no
you gotta choose one of those choices
but this isn't like choke you out to
sleep on you uh even with the Hang right
you always see them like it's like well
maybe it's the same thing I don't know
I've never been chilled out to sleep no
I think I think the the hanging is
probably the worst way to go probably
because out of the two you want somebody
Jiu Jitsu choke you I think that'd be
the sweetest like if I was like yo I
[ __ ] up Bart killed me and then he
chokes me but then but then since I'm
his friend over
that's quite the sweetest way to go out
that's what I'm saying I see sometimes
though that people are like kind of
trying to fight that and then they like
slowly like yeah but that's different
from when we see them in the movies and
they're like and then they're like
pupils turn red and [ __ ] yeah it's like
a little different is this same though
yeah oh yeah this one
because this one's nice and slow right
the blood and then like even when you
like practice doing it you'll have
someone will hold their hand up and then
as soon as their hand drops like okay
this guy's unconscious let go the other
one is just like it's like blood and
windpipe choke all at once this is more
of like a blood choke right like you're
just slowly stopping karate yeah you
just slowly preventing the blood from
going to the brain but the Rope one it's
like blood and windpipe and everything
whatever the [ __ ] the windpipe is the
painful part whatever the [ __ ] you got
going on yeah human anatomy
that's all going
yeah I'll change my answer long drop
then
excuse me you're convinced me so you can
have both yeah combo capital punishment
doesn't work capital punishment in Japan
is also quote shrouded in secrecy and
can allegedly take place without much
warning okay so executions in Japan are
shout outs you can see with prisoners
typically given only a few hours notice
they don't tell you until like they and
some are given no warning at all before
their death sentences are carried out
that's so scary I do remember Joe
telling me this
where in Japan I've been to like freak
them the [ __ ] out let's say he deserves
a death penalty
he could be in jail for 10 years or he
could be in it for a day and they won't
tell you it just happens so every day
you're living in here oh God that's
crazy they'll sentence you already
they're like hey you're gonna die by
hanging but we don't tell you where yeah
oh my God that is so [ __ ] up that's
that is that's me eating cake fake outs
too today right they put you they put
your head through yeah and then they go
no we're just kidding yeah not today
yeah today not today not today
[Music]
what's got going on in there you got one
more day or two who knows you imagine it
they just go all the way it's like a 15
minute thing they're like [ __ ] put
you through it and then they go three
two
just kidding
that's a [ __ ] up jail dude or even the
[ __ ] floor drops and then you get
caught by Sumo he's like ah just kidding
I spent all this budget to do these fake
outs they love the pranks dude they love
the videos
I got to you Japanese game show there's
a hidden camera over there
the jail is like we have budget problems
too much on fake outs too much
he says that whole thing
holy [ __ ] but he doesn't know the rust
backstory yeah at all
he's like I love 30 rocks
he doesn't know look at it he's just
like yo what the [ __ ] what are you doing
here
in them getting no warning uh at all
before death sentences sometimes
um their families the part I think about
it it says their families are usually
notified about the execution only after
it's taken place oh that's cool it's
their family is that also just like when
they get even if they know their kid or
whatever uh has a capital punishment
like that they don't know when it's
gonna happen but when it does happen
they're just like it happened so scary
for the family too holy [ __ ] but I feel
like the inmates they're either like
really Zen every day or they're like
living in fear because if you accept it
and you go I want to be a good person in
order like oh man I'm just gonna [ __ ]
try to rape everybody to great great
yeah great great everybody yeah
so uh there's also reports that inmates
sentenced to death have their next
swiftly broken using a rope and trap
door so that's better than you know very
very slow hopefully a black hood is
placed over inmates heads and they are
also blindfolded before prison officers
simultaneously press buttons releasing
the trapdoor without giving away which
button actually opens oh vitamin like
lights happen it's all wrong button like
a disco ball
crazy parties here in prison that's cool
they do the firing squad style though
where no one knows who's responsible
because everyone so you don't have to
live with that yeah that's cool guards
like make fun of each other they're like
I bet you did it I bet it was you that
did it they're like they're like three
two one
what's he do
dude I'm sure you have to have a sense
of humor or a [ __ ] job like that man
all right yeah exactly seven people line
up to press but you're joking around
everybody pressed some you didn't the
guy's still there you're like oh [ __ ]
the idea if every button still does
something like yours will just go
that'd be so tight and then the one guy
who's like hey mine's not making oh
are you sure mine doesn't work meanwhile
like 100 people you keep pressing people
are getting hung everywhere oh my God or
the trap doors going like this and he's
not going in he just goes oh yeah dude
that's crazy you should run out of
prison I think
how does is anyone here like really like
not gonna shame you but do you not want
death penalty to exist at all yeah me I
think it's good no group thank you guys
I actually think I remember I wrote a
paper about it in high school about the
tax to pay the tax dollars I was against
it because of the tax dollars it was
just like picking pick a controversial
topic and then argue about it and that
was just mine and I was like oh I
learned a lot about the death penalty
but that was it mine and my thing like
that in I think sixth grade was about
gun control and I was completely against
it
teacher was like what are you reading
what were you saying I just didn't think
it was necessary guns are against guns
no I was four guns yeah it's tight but I
didn't I don't think I fully understood
why
didn't heard the sound
sounds so cool I think it was a pretty
[ __ ] paper but yeah yeah same old
mine so you're are you like mildly
against death penalty no I I really
don't have a horse on Race dude
immediately I feel like uh I think uh I
don't have enough knowledge to have an
opinion on it I think it's nice to have
death penalty because it's nice
was it sweet because if you have like a
100 Year sentence and then you're
getting
graved it every day yeah I don't want to
then I'm just gonna so you're doing a
sympathy for the criminals yeah or or
like uh you're like I don't wanna you
know in order for the taxes really like
uh okay I'll pick you back up all right
plagiarism at its finest that was the
10th grade I didn't know but that what
is the real thing you know because uh we
paid less yeah yeah maybe it's like 30
to 40 Granite inmate per year yeah
I remember in this in 2001 Maryland
spent 18 million dollars trying to kill
one person so yeah damn Maryland yeah
spent 18 million trying to kill one
person well to try them and then to put
them on death row who is this person he
was a magician that's why he kept
getting on the Rope yeah yeah he was
really good at escaping yeah knowing U.S
that's one of the things it's only the
ropes like you get the death penalty
it's like death by hanging and then
you're like uh I have to appeal because
my client is allergic to rope wait dude
yeah that's kind of close three years
later you get retrials ah sorry we have
to appeal again you waited too long and
my client has mental issues remember
they appealed because the dude was
scared of needles
yeah and it worked they were like Okay
We're not gonna do that then that
happens that happens more frequently
than not Humanity of the human like the
humane way of death well that's such a
funny thing because actually this guy
Kato or Tomo hirokato in Japan when he
was kind of like the guy who brought
back the death penalty Hiatus of Japan
following his hang over the summer the
director of Amnesty International Japan
expressed his outrage of the decision
and branded the execution as inhumane
saying that the hanging of tomahiro Kato
is a callous attack on the right to life
regardless of the crimes he had
committed he should never have suffered
the ultimate cruel inhumane and
degrading treatment at the hands of the
state this is also a guy who like
stabbed or something like eight people
so so what's the I've heard like
arguments that kind of
um
for for like against the death penalty
but then whenever I hear of like the
crime that the person did I just can't
get behind like why we wouldn't kill him
I feel like if you kill one person maybe
accidentally or purposely maybe you get
like a trial but then if you kill two
person at separate times then you if you
kill two person at the same time then
maybe not or three person on accident
but if it's like a habit habit yeah if
you do the second time then you could
die immediately because you do it again
you just did it one time you're gonna
get it do it again you can have your fun
the first time no I mean right why is
one time man whatever oh no I get what
you're trying to say what Jay's trying
to say is he's like look you have your
you major accidents in the first time
everybody make mistakes everybody makes
mistakes what up Nick what if Nick gets
into an accident and it's genuine car
accident he just kills somebody right
yeah and then he also gets through a
genuine accident again so he has to die
I would I would kill myself the third
time dude you can't do it twice you
gotta die because it's like dude what
are you doing what are you doing
his first time he means to shoot
somebody in the face yeah but he never
kills the person a second time then he
gets a he gets a thing he gets a thing
he gets he gets it like uh okay fine I
don't get to go to jail no no no you
still go to jail a little bit no you
can't kill somebody on purpose yeah on
purpose I did kill him yeah yeah but he
killed two people on accident two
different times seems more of a danger
you yeah I agree here's my question can
it be proven that that it's an accident
and can it be proven that it's
intentional yes because I am looking at
the nest camera
I'm gonna kill him
it's set for freedom but the nest
cameras
[Laughter]